so Richard Dawkins is working on a
children's book which he hopes will
indoctrinate children into atheism and
this brings to mind a question that I
that I've always wondered about I find
myself always perplexed by the sort of
evangelical atheism espoused by guys
like Dawkins and I'm not gonna use
Dawkins as the prime example because I
know that even atheists are embarrassed
by Dawkins and for good reason
but he's far from the only evangelical
atheists there are this is this is a
pretty common thing especially among
modern atheists there are great many of
them who who although they're less
obnoxious than Richard Dawkins I still
find them just as perplexing because
evangelical atheism that is to go around
preaching atheism and trying to convert
people to it just seems so pointless and
it seems like it is not really in the
spirit of atheism to be evangelical
about it so I want to try to work
through this and figure it out and to
begin we have to go back to the basics
and and start with what is atheism what
a way theists believe well if you are an
atheist and and if you are a rational
atheist who has fully thought things
through and if you fully comprehend the
implications of your worldview then you
must believe that life has no objective
meaning or purpose
now you can infuse purpose and meaning
into it subjectively but objectively it
has no great purpose because an order
for a thing to have a purpose that
purpose has to come from above it and
beyond it so a hammer that is just
floating in the ocean by itself in the
middle of the Pacific has no purpose it
does it just it's just there it's just
floating and it has no purpose
whatsoever
[Music]
in order for a it would what gives a
hammer purpose
the reason why it has purpose is that
there are nails to be hammered and there
is a person to pick up the hammer and
use it to drive a nail into a board and
to build like a house and a house has a
purpose because there are people to live
in it
so there is this in order to have
purpose there's something beyond
something above something that kind of
trance transcends it so by that equation
people have purpose because why what is
the objective purpose of a person
well I would say our objective that we
have an objective purpose because we
have a God to serve but without God the
purpose can no longer be real no longer
be objective and solid there is whatever
purpose you can find whatever makes you
happy and numbs the pain but in reality
we're just bags of meat floating in a
random and infinite abyss so if that if
that hammer floating in the ocean were
ever to unfortunately become self-aware
then it would I guess it will need to
come up with some kind of subjective
purpose for its existence floating in
the ocean although I guess a hammer
wouldn't really float in the ocean what
it would be probably sick but still um
let's say a hammer at the bottom of the
ocean becomes self-aware it may want to
come up with some reason for its own
existence just so we can deal with the
with the terrible agony of its existence
but in reality it has no purpose it's
just a thing down at the bottom of the
ocean on on atheism
that's kind of what we are we we all are
we're all just things floating around
the earth itself is just a things
careening through space it's just a
thing we're all just things so there can
be no greater no transcendent meaning to
existence existence is just existence
we are all just the sum of our own parts
and our parts our material our parts are
just stuff our stuff happens to be
assembled this way a hammer stuff is
assembled that way a tree's stuff is
assembled another way a rocks stuff is
assembled still another way but
objectively our existence has no meaning
that is greater than the meaning of a
rock or a tree it has no purpose greater
than a rock or trees purpose because
we're all stuffed we are stuff that has
come together by chance and which will
soon disintegrate into the oblivion and
so that's it non-existence you are from
the Atheist view heading into
non-existence the total cessation of
being all that you have ever done
everything you've ever thought said all
of that will be erased and forgotten
everything that you are will fade into
the void and amount to nothing and mean
nothing everyone you ever loved your
spouse your children your parents your
friends they will they're all headed for
the same void and once they've entered
it they are gone all is gone and all
that's ever happened to you ultimately
will mean an amount to nothing this is
the Atheist view even if you don't go
around saying it that is your view we
are all just headed for nothingness and
once you are in the nothingness nothing
matters anymore so then the question is
why do you care what people believe if
people find meaning in as you say a
fairy tale well good for them what do
you care well what would what possible
reason could you have for caring that
people believe in a fairy tale and of
course I don't think religion is a fairy
tale but by your view it is what I
really can't understand is if I were to
ever adopt that view I wouldn't why
would I care what other people believe
now there's a reason why a Christian
cares what you believe because we
believe that there is a life beyond this
one and it and what happens in that life
beyond this one matters very depends
very much on you know what you believe
in what you do in this life and so
that's why we're not you could say that
we're crazy you don't agree but it makes
sense why we are evangelical about it it
doesn't make any sense why you would be
considering we are you and I both in a
few years were just nothing what does it
matter
just like so I believe a fairy tale let
me believe the fairy tale why could you
possibly care about this what's the
point you know Karl Marx says that
famously says that religion is the opium
of the people and okay fine so it's it's
something that people find to give them
hope and joy and pleasure in a
meaningless life that comes to nothing
in the end so why would you try to step
in the way of that why would you try to
take that away from them in fact it's
interesting that most atheists you talk
to are gonna be very libertarian about
actual drugs like actual opium so
they're gonna say that hey if somebody
wants to do heroin let them do heroin
yeah it's hurting them it might kill
them but if it makes them feel good if
it's what they want to do it's their
body let them do it it doesn't matter so
I don't understand how you could have
that opinion about actual drugs that are
actually directly physically killing
people and yet you don't have that view
of this mental or spiritual drug as you
see it so you have that view of actual
opium but the religious opium you say no
we must take that away from people why
well you might say that you do it
because religion is a blight on the
earth and it's led to great suffering
well that's also true of drugs by the
way and so but we'll leave that to the
side okay now that's that's not it's not
true of course religion has sometimes
been used as an excuse to hurt people
certain religions are much more often
used to that end than others but atheist
governments have also brought misery and
and and death on the masses on an
unprecedented scale I might add and if
you know anything about even recent
world history you must realize that and
atheists themselves individually I'm
sure you would admit are at least just
as likely to commit acts of violence and
evil as anyone else so that means that
you can't you can't brought blame
religion for for bad things that happen
but also you're an atheist so you know
that we're just animals we are we are
slaves to nature and nature is harsh
violent uncaring brutal
and you know as an atheist that we can
never rise above our nature because
there's nothing above our nature to rise
towards all is nature nature is
everything so to blame the evil and
violence in the world on religion is
absurd and you must know that evil and
violence are just nature it's just the
way of things it will never change it
can't change and why should we try to
change it you know a shark doesn't try
to change his ways and stop eating seals
a lion doesn't get all guilt-tripped if
he if he kills a zebra and then sees
that the zebra has a child he says oh my
oh my goodness what have I done he
doesn't do that a male gorilla will beat
another grill at a death and not even
think about it because this is just how
nature acts there's no chance of
escaping it and why should we try why
we're no different than the lion the the
gorilla the shark why should we be why
should we hold ourselves to a higher
standard
what is evil anyway you would never
speak of a shark or a line or a gorilla
or a virus committing evil would you no
matter how much death and suffering
those creatures bring on other creatures
you would never say that they commit
evil so so why should we be held to that
standard it's a social construct an
artificial invention a thing evil
doesn't even exist on atheism there's no
rational way to blame religion for evil
but there's also no such thing as evil
anyway
so that can't be a reason the idea that
religion is evil cannot be your you
can't possibly be a reason for trying to
convert people away from because
religion is no worse than atheism as far
as that goes I would argue it's better
but it's certainly no worse and also
evil doesn't exist so and this is all
just in keeping with with with the way
of nature like so you know let's say in
your and your in your worst case
scenario a religious government comes
into power and establishes this
oppressive theocracy and imposes its
will on others well that's just
Darwinism that's just doggy dog that's
that's what we're supposed to do right
that's what nature says that's how every
organism on the planet behaves so why
shouldn't you do that why shouldn't we
so I can't be reason what is it then
well you might say you preach atheism
because atheism is true and so you
preach it because what's true is true
and you preach it for the sake of truth
but who cares who cares if it's true
value does the truth have what is the
truth matter
our ability to even recognize the truth
as an aberration it's the result of a
mutation I would say it's a sick joke
that the universe has pulled on us there
are nine million other species on earth
hundreds of millions of species in the
history of the earth
none of them are or have ever been
self-aware none of them have the
capability of comprehending themselves
or death or truth
and scientists believe that there that
there could be a 99% probability that
were the only intelligent creatures in
the whole galaxy they say there's a 50
to 60 percent probability that were the
only intelligent creatures in the in the
known observable universe
somebody's worthy as far as we know we
are the only creatures in the observable
universe who have this self-awareness
this ability to see truth
and think about all the other matter in
the galaxy we all come from the same
stuff right where we're all essentially
the same in the end we're all just
inanimate matter that is assembled
itself in a certain way and for us it
assembled itself in a way as to produce
animation and to produce at least the
illusion of consciousness but we're all
just you know we're all we are all just
the sum of our parts and and so out of
all these trillions and trillions and
trillions of things in the universe we
are the only ones as far as we know that
have the capacity to know ourselves and
know truth the only ones now
I won't even get into the fact that this
doesn't really make any sense
you know reason cannot spring forth from
unreason consciousness cannot come from
unconsciousness it makes no sense that
that a universe of unreason a universe
with no self-awareness at all a universe
of matter with no designer and no God
could somehow feature one small little
race of of reasonable self-aware
creatures and what a horrible thing in
such a cold and pointless universe for
this lonely little collection of beings
to be cursed with the knowledge of the
futility of their own existence
and what a horrible thing that somehow
nature has has given us not only reason
but has also given us this infinite
longing for something beyond something
greater something that transcends
ourselves something that doesn't exist
we're also the only creatures in the
known universe as far as we know that
have that that have this great deep
desire for a non-existent thing
why would and why would nature evolve
such a desire doesn't make any sense
and why why would nature evolve from
from the atheist view they say well
nature evolved self-awareness for people
human beings evolved consciousness
because that's what we needed to
propagate our species but
well first of all you really had you
still haven't explained how that
actually functionally happens but also
how does consciousness how does
self-awareness help us propagate the
species the only thing nature is
concerned with right is this is just is
just the propagation of itself and and
there are many species that are more
numerous than we are and do not have
consciousness and do not have
self-awareness there are many species
that have existed heck of a heck of a
lot longer than us and do not have
consciousness and do not have
self-awareness in fact reason not only
doesn't help our species propagate but
it actually interferes with it it does
the opposite as reasonable beings we are
the only ones as far as we know that
actually make the decision to not
propagate the species so how could it
have come have come about it doesn't
make any sense but that's not the point
just trying to establish that our
capacity to understand truth is
accidental and I think pretty horrific
so
why are you appealing to it it's just
this totally meaningless and accidental
function that this function that we
happen to have that serves no great
purpose
why are you appealing to it who cares to
hell with truth in that case what does
it matter
the truth is a horror it would be better
if we don't confront it on the Atheist
view
not to mention how can we even trust our
perception of truth
if reason is just the result of unreason
assembling itself in a certain way
to trust our reason is to trust the
material irrational things that comprise
our reason and how do we do that reason
rationality these are but illusions in
the Atheist view rationality is a
projection of irrationality
so rationality doesn't really exist it's
just uh it's just you know an apple tree
can't give you bananas an apple tree can
only give you apples
well our roots our tree our trunk is
irrationality that is what we're
comprised of his irrational unconscious
matter
could the fruits be anything but
irrationality and unconsciousness
I think on atheism to really understand
and comprehend truth is to go insane it
is to see yourself as you are which is
you are not really a self you're not
you're no more a self then a clump of
dirt is a self
your perception of selfhood is illusory
you're just matter among matter you are
a collection of physical things you are
a lump of stuff and nothing more so if
you really want to live in the truth and
advocate for the truth then you would
have to live with the knowledge that
there is no you and everything you think
do say and believe it's just the result
of chemical interactions and so how can
you even trust it so it seemed on the
Atheist view there's no reason to appeal
to truth and you really can't because
how do you know you can trust your own
perception of truth so that can't be the
reason why atheist preach atheism
I think we're left with only three
possibilities one they really believe
that atheism is true they believe that
life is horrible and meaningless and
they want others to join them in their
despair it's a misery misery loves
company kind of thing and so it's really
it's really cruelty in the end and I
think that's the case for some of them
too
for other atheists I think they don't
really believe that atheism is true or
they aren't quite sure but they're angry
at God for any number of reasons so
their denial of him is their way of
lashing out at him and their recruiting
of other people is a rebellion against
God I think that's the case for some of
them but three I think that um many
atheists just haven't thought this all
the way out
they aren't trying to be cruel and they
don't perceive that they hate God they
don't consciously hate God they're not
consciously angry at him they truly
believe on some level that he doesn't
exist but they fight for what they
believe is true because they see the
truth as this transcendent and important
thing
they think that it is morally right to
speak truth
and they believe that we should live
according to what is morally right in
other words they disbelieve in God but
their hearts and their souls I would say
are pulling them towards this
recognition of a world where truth is
transcendent and moral rightness is
worth fighting for and I think that's
good now I think they're wrong and a lot
of their conclusions but the motivation
there at least that part of the
motivation is good
I just wish they'd stop to think about
where they got this idea of of truth and
this idea of right and wrong
now if you're an atheist and you really
think that religion is a moral
abomination and so you fight for it on
that ground you fight for it because you
say well I thought
to fight against religion and a person
ought not be religious
well the moment that you've made that
statement then you have to
then you have to ask yourself where did
you get this conception of ought to or
not not to
no other creature on earth has that
conception no other you don't have
squirrels and deer running around saying
well I ought to do this or I shouldn't
do that
they never think that
so where did you get that from that's
interesting isn't this idea of I ought
to I ought not to and what happens now
if if you're doing something and someone
comes up to you and says you ought not
do that what is your first question to
them what is it it's says who and so if
you're committing a crime and someone
subs that comes up and says you ought
not do that and you say says who they
might say well the government says it
and if you do it you're go to jail and
so fine that's a reason but if you're
doing something that is not illegal and
it's just immoral
and someone comes up to you and says I
well you ought not do that and then you
say says who
well what's the answer to that every
time you say ought to or ought not to
you are appealing to an authority of
some kind
you must be because if there is no
authority if there is no command or law
or rule that we're supposed to be
following that it makes no sense to say
ought to or not not to if there is no
God if there's no objective moral code
ingrained in us from above then your
conception of what we should do and
shouldn't do means nothing because when
I say says who you'd have to say well
nobody nobody says it and then I can say
okay well then what that's okay but I'm
going to keep doing it
you
so
all I would ask is if you're an atheist
maybe follow your own train of thought
you say you don't believe in God okay
yet you still see truth as this thing
that we should strive towards
and you seals you still see moral
rightness as an objective good
so it seems like you're reaching for
something you're reaching for something
that is above and beyond nature you're
reaching for something that is not
contained in nature and obviously was
not created by nature so all I would ask
you to think to yourself is what am i
reaching to or maybe I should say Who am
I reaching to
just something to think about thank you
for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed everybody